hello there and welcome to Playstation
grenade I've been looking around the
PlayStation Store again and have yet
another list of 10 video games you can
play for free on your feet s4 if you
haven't seen the first list I'll link it
at the end of the video and if I've
missed any beauty - please let me know
below if this is obvious to you please
give us a like and think about sharing
this with friends okay let's do this
let's start off with a King's tale from
Final Fantasy 15 this originated as a
pre-order bonus for Final Fantasy 15
but since has been secretly added to the
PlayStation Store for absolutely free in
this one you'll be taking part on a
side-scrolling 16-bit era mission which
takes about 90 minutes to complete if
you were a fan of Streets of Rage or the
old Turtles arcade game this one is for
you
the soundtrack is amazing the melee
focus fighting is perfectly paced and if
you're a fan of Final Fantasy 15 it
feeds into your understanding of the
characters and if you don't like Final
Fantasy well don't worry it doesn't play
anything like that type of game it's
basically a flashback of events
preceding Final Fantasy 15 and centers
on Regis reliving his adventures from
back in the day seeing klaris join a
fight at your command
let's go back in time to the first free
game released on ps4 initially warframe
was released in November 2013 and was a
solid shooter but a little buggy and
unresponsive at times well many people
tried it and deleted it but almost four
years later this game is still receiving
updates and has developed into a silent
jet for the PlayStation community this
game now has a 4.5 rating out of a
possible five stars on the sauce and
just look how sexy it is over the past
few years the Destiny influence has
become prominent and it feels like Metal
Gear revengeance in places to over a
quarter of a million players are still
regularly playing online if you are
strapped for cash and want a solid
shooter success your time into and look
no further than warframe did you ever
play NBA Jam it was bloody great wasn't
it well there is a game available for
free on your ps4 which follows in that
gaming vein it's called three on three
freestyle the art style is
family-friendly with a similar style to
earth of Team Fortress and is quite
sassy like that too you have a plethora
of characters to choose from which you
can also change the appearance off to
stand out from the crowd the
ever-present free player area allows you
to hone your skills and switch
characters to find which one suits you
the best
is this a great game well no it isn't
but warframe has shown us that sometimes
these free-to-play games improve over
time
[Music]
another thriving community built up in
2013 came from the game war thunder this
is a military vesicular warfare MMO
allowing you to pilot aircraft tank and
wash it the beauty of this title is the
cross-platform gameplay which allows ps4
players and PC players to team up on the
battlefield or go up against each other
there are single-player portions to this
game too so if you don't want to battle
online and learn the basics in your own
time the community are quite mature if
you choose to open your comms you
shouldn't find any 13 year olds who have
your mum which is always nice to hear
isn't it 800 vehicles 18 maps 32 players
and eight years of ongoing support from
the developer - have you tried it what
do you think
there's a beast deep inside you it will
not die it is granted to a chosen few
skies boys was released on the ps4 at
the same week as this video I haven't
spent enough time with it to either
recommend it or warn you to run a mile
so please keep that in mind
[Music]
this is a massively multiplayer online
role-playing game set in a fantasy
universe filled with science-fiction
elements first released in 2014 on the
PC we finally have the option to play
this one on PlayStation almost three
years later it's a well-put-together
game with a solid focus on action quite
a dynamic combat system it's hidden
under the hood with impressive combos
projectiles and all the typical classes
you'd expect to find with 14 unlockable
characters and up to 99 players on the
same server this one could be the one to
take over your life thinking of trying
it let us know below how about a mech
focused title well hawk and could be the
game for you release less than a year
ago Hawking takes elements from zona
vendors titanfall and MechWarrior and
successfully smashes all three products
together on one side you have fast paced
action on the other side it's more about
planning and a good knowledge of the
battlefield is very much required
especially when your character is
healing 13 mechs were launched with the
game with more updates happening
regularly this one is a whole lot of fun
and judging by the matchmaking it
requires more players desperately
APB Reloaded pops up in march 2017 and
grabbed my attention when the xbox
community dubbed it the worst game ever
made it looks like a GTA clone and tries
to play that way too you can choose to
be a hardened criminal or a licensed
vigilante which i think means you're
like a rogue cop the idea to have two
opposing factions is great but the more
time I spend in this world the more I
want to take a long walk off a short
clip textures just don't load sometimes
the framerate drops constantly and it's
a steaming pile of excrement but someone
must live it out there is it you won for
those little people in your life and by
that I mean children not dwarves and
Oompa Loompas anyway troll is another
MMO which are everywhere on the
PlayStation Store at the moment this one
embraces pixel art cel shading and
minecraft approach to voxel gaming by
the way voxel means 3d space like volume
depth height so go impress your friends
with the new word you've just learned
anyway you're going to build a lot
you're going to discover quite a few
things you're going to fight all within
this friendly atmosphere with this
lovely color scheme if you've played
Minecraft in a public server and you've
seen your building burn to the ground
then trove is here to help by building
upon something called a cornerstone in
this world you can protect your home
from random events and those little
buggers that try to destroy everything
you make
thanks troll
[Music]
the Tomorrow Children released on the
PlayStation Store late in 2016 in this
one you play as a young girl answering
the call of the motherland which could
not sound more Russian if you tried this
is a blend of action simulation strategy
and a few social elements to supporting
up to 45 players to solve the game
quickly I describe it as resource
gathering in order to build a city with
occasional platforming and combat
elements - I'm super confused by this
one so please let me know your thoughts
below
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's finish off with a bit of a classic
DC Universe Online was released in 2013
and in yet another mmm Oh
but with recognizable characters that
you look I brought this back to your
attention due to the sudden influx of
superhero movies cartoons and just
general merchandise to be on it
as Batman is building the Justice League
in the films why not jump into DC online
and build your own ragtag group of
heroes although it's old it still has
enough quality to give you a great comic
book we'll ride every DC superhero
supervillain is here so if you haven't
tried it yet grab an old bedsheet as a
cape wear your underwear on the outside
and talk into a glass yeah nickel bloody
revenge your reign ends now
okay
so that ten-mile free-to-play games that
you can grab now on the PlayStation
stock hopefully you didn't know about
all of these I'd really like to know
what you think about these games and
what rating you would give them Oh on a
quick note we'll soon be getting
paladin's which should be free-to-play -
to my domain
because of what the great as soon as I
know more about that I'll confirm it
with you guys and be back here with
another free game update I'm Adam from
playstation grenades and I'll see you
next time I will make this a horrific
scene of bloodshed
don't know which you all yes I will see
you next time
what that's a terrible impression